bias old house buyers could speak to you
this morning so
what obviously your chair of these sort
of committees talk to us about what will
happen how will we deliver the news and
what might happen next well if I make
can I just first um express my
condolences for what's happened in
Nottingham with people's lives just torn
apart uh by uh this tragedy that's taken
place and uh very much have thoughts and
prayers with all those who are affected
um my goodness you know a key role of
members of parliament is to communicate
so let me make this very very clear
indeed colleagues have peaked already on
this issue as indeed I think a nation
has too the longer this public pantomime
drags on you know the more Boris loses
support from a once very loyal base and
then the more labor policies avoid
scrutiny and the more the prime
minister's plans and vision which was
starting to gain traction are over
shadowed the public actually want us to
get back to politics Johnson has
resigned his seat before the report was
published I should say rather than
taking his arguments and presenting them
to the commons which he could have done
this is looking increasingly desperate
and this should not really be the legacy
of any prime minister all dragging on a
distraction from us as I say focusing on
these more important issues the state of
the economy interest rates cost of
living crisis and of course Ukraine it's
time to draw a line and move forward and
I hope the the release of this
publication today whether it will allow
us to do that
meantime speaking of distractions Boris
Johnson has highlighted what he refers
to uh
in relation to saberna Jenkin he's part
of the committee as you know
um and he allegedly went to a drinks
party held by the commons Deputy speaker
Dame Ellen alang in December of 2020
while London was in tier two measures
restricting indoor mixing as a result
the former prime minister says first of
all sir Bernard Jenkins should have
recused himself he didn't and now he
should resign what do you think
well I'm not aware that Bernard Jenkin
misled Parliament
um that allocation against Savannah
Jenkins will first need to be
investigated by the police uh the report
States very very clearly uh the
publication that there is no basis for
Johnson's claim that senior officials
gave him assurances but covert guidance
had not been broken and that's pretty
black and white and yet Boris Johnson
has said many times that he received no
assurances
um so if Boris Johnson is unhappy with
the committee findings or indeed anybody
on the committee the personalities and
so forth he could easily have made a
personal statement in the comments
that's the process and presented his
arguments prior to a full vote of the
house because it will be for the house
to determine whether they support this
publication or not he's chosen to
abandon all those possible Avenues of
approach and quit parliament in its
entirety so now coming late in the day
to say I'm unhappy with an individual
this isn't the process of somebody I
believe who is going to win the argument
it's interesting I was reading the
papers this morning I'm sure you have as
well
um to buy zelwood where
um the reference to
the former prime minister Boris Johnson
potentially trying to portray himself as
a martyr that it's a kangaroo court that
it's been a Witch Hunt
um is he trying to pave the way for a
potential comeback
well of course this is his long-term
intention but let me make it really
clear Johnson's confidence stemmed from
the huge support he received from the
party base that was really really clear
he was loved by members across the
country but this is changing before our
very eyes there's now disappointment
even anger that the party the activists
are left to pick up the pieces with
limited time to repair this Fallout as
the next election looms ever closer you
know I say this directly to the few
individuals who are still fueling this
new cycle is this really what you want
your legacy to be putting self-interest
before party before the country
deliberately harming dozens of MPS
prospects of holding them onto their
seats at the next elections you know if
your Idols are Margaret Thatcher and
Winston Churchill if they were around
what would they make of your behavior
our party was beginning to regroup as
our prime minister navigates us and to
have a calmer more sensible Waters and
return to fiscal responsibility this
government is expected to bring forward
you know a vote it's important that uh
Parliament is seen to complete the
process I hope when that vote takes
place we can now draw that line
um to that end um thoughts on Nadine
Doris what would you say to uh Nadine
you've made your decision off you go or
is she right to go to owner's pace and
time
well I include that in uh what I've just
said because when you have two
by-elections taking place but a third
delayed until potentially we return in
September this just drags the damage out
it does nobody any favors whatsoever it
harms the party it's not good for the
nation it distracts the government so
please let's send in your letter to the
chancellor make it clear that you're
stepping back allow those by-elections
to all to take place on one day it will
be tough for us there's no doubt about
it but there's enough time between now
and the general election and for us to
sell out State our stall as to how we
intend to govern the country so people
can make a fair comparator between
whether they want labor and potentially
higher taxes or a conservative party run
by Richie sunac running the country
okay
um it's always a pleasure to buy zelwood
thank you